hello everybody it's that time of year
again we're close to the end of 2021 and
so it's time to solicit suggestions and
then we'll do a vote
for some of the authors for the worlds
of speculative fiction series coming up
in 2022 now some people might be a
little confused what's the worlds of
speculative fiction it's a series that i
originally did in person and then video
recording and then eventually in covid
time shifted to all online that began in
2016
and is continuing on to the present
we've covered a lot of authors a lot of
texts and the focus is on exploring
philosophical themes and narrative
worlds so you know looking for example
at the lord of the rings and middle
earth or the alliance union universe of
cj chera or all sorts of other things
where there's a shared narrative
universe that we can explore
so i have some
authors and texts already lined up
mostly series in fact
going all the way from january to
september so nine different
installations for 2022 but i want some
some suggestions some input from you
the people who might be interested in
what other sessions we could do for the
other three sessions of 2022
now i'm going to tell you who we're
covering in 2022 in just a moment i do
want to remind you before you make your
suggestions you want to go to the worlds
of speculative fiction playlist and see
whether the thing that you're tempted to
suggest has already been
covered if it has then there will be a
video or sometimes videos about it for
instance if you're going to suggest our
scott backers prince of nothing series
we covered that this year with three
different installations or ursula k le
guin's earth c series that i think we
did last year with two different
installations so you want to make sure
that the suggestions that you're giving
are things we
haven't already explored and then what
i'm going to do
is take the suggestions that you leave
in your comments
and i'll go through and see whether
there's any that are getting a lot of
traction and i'll come up with a list of
the top six
and then you get to vote on
those maybe maybe i'll actually do top
four we'll see it depends on how i set
up the survey but you get input at two
different points first giving
suggestions
and then we winnow those and come up
with the best suggestions for a vote and
the top votes will get into
the series for next year so series for
next year who are we covering
i have been a little bit stalled in
reading through a
fan suggestion book that is very long
and very dense neil stephenson's anathem
and i'm gonna do that one in january i
had intended originally to do it in
november and then i kicked it down to
december of this year but we're gonna do
it in january and start out with that
then in february we're going to do
phillip pullman's his dark materials
trilogy northern lights the subtle knife
the amber spy glass so if you're into
that that is a session you won't want to
miss
march we're going to do octavia's but
octavia butler's parable novel so we're
coming back to butler who we've already
done with our xenogenesis series parable
of the sower parable of the talents
in april we'll we'll be taking on a
fan suggested one that people have been
asking for for quite a while olaf
stapleton also a philosopher so i'm
really looking forward to delving into
his works we're going to do three of his
novels last and first men last men in
london and star maker and then in may
we're going to do veronica roth's carve
the mark series which includes carve the
mark the fates divide and then some of
the stories in the end and other
beginnings i actually got to meet roth a
couple years ago when she was on a book
tour for the end and other beginnings
and i
co-presented with her here in milwaukee
at boswell books a really fun
time you know i enjoyed these stories so
we're going to go into those then in
june we're going to go way back into the
archives and continue something that we
started in the very first year
so roger zelazny
did
the chronicles of amber and we talked
about the first five books that center
around
one main character and a bunch of other
characters of course
introducing ideas of law and chaos and
all sorts of cool things like that
we're going to continue that one in june
with the
the five following stories that center
instead of around corwin they center
around merlin his son trumps of doom
blood of amber sign of chaos night of
shadows prince of chaos those were
coming out while i was in high school
and college i really enjoyed them so
hopefully you know they hold up over
time in july we're going to return to
something that i've been promising to do
for a long time people have been asking
about jg ballard so we're going to look
at his modern dystopias with crash
concrete island and high rise in august
we're going to come back to philip k
dick somebody who we've done several
times this time we're going to be
focusing on the theme of androids and
humans and looking at his speech
of the the same name so we're going to
look at we can build you to android's
dream of electric sheep the simulacrum
and some of the short stories like
imposter and nanny and we'll probably
add some to the list in september
margaret atwood's gilead dystopia
stories the handmaid's tale and her
recently published the testaments and
that takes us up to the fourth quarter
of the year where you get to have some
input into what we'll be
doing you can help decide what other
text authors narrative universes we
ought to go into so leave your comments
below again make sure that you
look at the worlds of speculative
fiction playlist so that you're not
suggesting something that we've already
covered
try to suggest something new something
that you're interested in something that
you'd like me to tackle and to go into
the philosophical themes and narrative
universe and discuss and like and then
offer as i do i create a video and then
i offer a session after the video for us
to engage in video conferencing
discussion about it so that's it
the job for you is to
take a look at what's already been done
see what you would like to have added
for the last three sessions of the
worlds of speculative fiction coming up
in 2022 and tune in if any of these
sounded interesting to you right we're
doing uh neil stephenson phillip pullman
octavia butler ola stapleton veronica
roth roger zelazny jg ballard phillip
dick and margaret atwood next year if
any of those sound interesting to you
then put it on your calendar you can
find
when and where these are going to be on
the reason io calendar right available
at reasonio.com
you can find them on my facebook page
once i actually put them up there i
announce these well in advance so you
know they're always on on saturdays
usually beginning at noon central time
so you have a lot of opportunity to
participate in these i hope that you've
got some interesting suggestions for me
and i look forward to seeing what you
have to say
you